let's start today talking about food
shortages there is a new story line a
new narrative claims that food shortages
are imminent in the united states and
that there's going to be no food the
shelves will be bare as the failed
former president donald trump would
often like to say uh joe biden even said
it this was about three weeks ago and
the context was the russian invasion of
ukraine and the related sanctions and
responses here's joe biden three weeks
ago nothing more to report with regard
to food shortage yes we did we
still talk about food shortages
and uh and it's going to be real the the
price of these sanctions is not just
imposed upon russia it's imposed upon an
awful lot of countries as well including
european countries and our country as
well so on the other hand we also have
kind of the more hyperbolic
fear-based kind of reactionary claims
here's one example from right wing host
dan bongino who had a segment called the
devastating food crisis is coming please
prepare now and the preppers loving this
the food crisis coming up it's a topic
we've covered on the show and the radio
show often right there's a devastating
food crisis coming ladies and gentlemen
and you darn well better be prepared
listen i care about you
a lot i'm not kidding i love the
audience it's why there's an email on
our website that's why i leave the
facebook page open for your messages
right i am here for you i am one of you
i came from you i'm a middle-class kid
who had a middle-class job with a
middle-class life
okay so anyway
without his full biography the point is
the right is increasingly saying food
shortages are coming many of the people
predicting the food shortages will also
sell you food packaged food
bonus buckets there's a lot of comments
if you look at the dam bon gino piece
where people saying
from my bible study group we can get
food and all of this different stuff so
let's talk it through is it possible
that we could have a food shortage of
course
of course
there have been food shortages in
history and they are possible
the first step in really thinking
critically about this is what do we mean
by a food shortage because there are
some people who seem to think
that a food shortages
my favorite orange juice wasn't
available i had to get pulp instead of
no pulp or i like turkey bacon but there
was no turkey bacon so i had to consider
regular bacon or
plant-based bacon
that's not really a food shortage now
i'm gonna get to that which is the
products we expect just aren't there
okay we're going to talk about that in a
moment but a food shortage when we talk
about it economically is there's not
enough energy or there's close to not
enough energy meaning calories available
for the proper nutrition of a population
and i would even go further
i would say there's not enough calories
available from a reasonably diverse set
of foods what i mean by that is
imagine that in order to meet our
caloric needs everybody had to be
drinking corn syrup like okay we'd be
getting our calories but i would still
consider that to be a food shortage
because it's not a calorie shortage but
it's definitely a shortage of a
reasonably diverse diet so the first
question is is an actual shortage based
on that softer definition not even going
to be able to really get the food groups
we need is that likely this year based
on the evidence we have and the answer
is no
it's hard to say more but there's not
going to be
a food group calorie deficit there's
going to be enough meat
there's going to be enough dairy there's
going to be enough produce there will be
enough grains
um
we're not going to actually have a
shortage of calories from any particular
food group
now
might there be a situation where in
portland oregon
there's no chicken breast for a day at
the local store and you've got to get
chicken thigh
yeah that that could happen those things
anecdotally are happening and we'll talk
about why in a moment but my store was
out of a particular cookie and so i had
to get the milano you know i mean
most of us aren't savages so we get dark
chocolate you might have to get the milk
chocolate i know it's not good it's ugly
i get it it's ugly i you know i'm for
dark chocolate as much as the next guy
but uh that's not really a food shortage
right the shelves aren't bare now let's
get into what might happen just so we
all know and we're aware and we're
prepared
is it possible that specific products
might ebb and flow in their supply
so that you might have to choose
something different that you're used to
getting yeah that is possible and that's
definitely different than what most of
us in the united states are used to
the war in ukraine
is likely to disrupt wheat and sunflower
seed oil and sunflower seed oil is
actually
in a lot of foods that many of us buy
but it's more likely to be disruptive to
countries other than the united states
the u.s is actually a big wheat exporter
and producer poorer nations that demand
that rely more heavily on on imports of
wheat are going to be more at risk for
example so like the wheat issue will hit
egypt indonesia bangladesh pakistan
turkey some other countries there will
likely not be
shortages but there might be some
limited availability of meat dairy and
some animal products
there might also be a shortage
of
lack of availability i think is the word
i should say of some plant-based vegan
proteins those for two reasons one
there are some people who if they don't
see the meat that they want they might
try the plant-based alternative the
plant-based alternatives are also highly
processed foods and the supply chain
can't be accelerated that easily a lot
of those processed items you you can't
easily adjust the supply chain quickly
it can take six to nine months so you
might see that so we might see slight
sporadic regional temporary lack of
availability of certain products now
what could cause the appearance of an
actual shortage
panic buying like we saw early in the
pandemic
and in that case
you know is it really a shortage if a
ton of people are pre-purchasing
a year's worth of whatever and what i
mean by that is think back to the
so-called toilet paper shortage
there was no toilet paper on the shelves
that's true
but the reason was that a ton of people
bought a year's supply so they're good
now for a year and as we saw once the
supply
normalized we had fewer people buying
the toilet paper because they
pre-purchased it in the first month of
the pandemic so that was an apparent
shortage it wasn't a real shortage it's
also by the way interesting how a lot of
the producers of some of these foods
tyson perdue for example in poultry
they've had
record profits above and beyond the rate
of inflation so it's not just inflation
that's driving their profit at a time of
allegedly significantly higher costs to
them so i'm not ready to say that there
is price gouging going on
but it is interesting that profit
margins remain at record highs despite
supposedly higher costs and inflation
and all of that so we're going to follow
it that's the best assessment we have
right now
based on the information that we have
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night improves sleep
in many ways our sponsor chilly sleep
creates systems that cool down your bed
promoting deeper higher quality sleep it
also just feels great i use it at home
i'd recommend it to anyone and i've
recommended it to some friends who now
use it as well chili sleeps product the
uhler the cube and the doc pro
they're all water-based temperature
controlled pads that fit onto your
existing mattress you can keep your bed
as low as 55 degrees as hot as 115
degrees i like 60 their new doc pro
sleep system has double the cooling
power of other models five times the
cooling contact whisper quiet you can
control it with your phone it's awesome
with chilly sleep there's no more
feeling hot at night no more sweating
cooling your bed down like this is
amazing you really have to try it for
yourself when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman you'll get thirty percent off of
the uhler and cube sleep systems and ten
percent off the new doc pro this offer
is only for my audience the link is down
below